foreign
what's going on guys
you guys know what time it is
i've been cursed
what the responsibility of playing
these old ass games
and today
is
the start
of playing
shinobi
for the xbox
backwards compatible thing i assume
this is what i'm supposed to play
i hope
this is what i'm supposed to play
i reserve all rights
to have
ignorance in this case
and if this isn't what i'm supposed to
play
there is no recap there is no redo
there's this and this only
and i'm only gonna play
one stream that's all
unless you guys are real generous in
that chat and you guys show up with the
super chats with the likes with the
viewership with the conversations in
general
i might stream this game again
but for right now
this is a one and done thing
but let me go ahead and
put this on twitter let me go ahead and
and show the world that i'm playing
this nonsense
so briefly give me a moment
what have you guys been up to by the way
you guys been having a good day
i hope so
because you guys are making me
play this nonsense
but i promised i would do it
because
i'm a man of my word
hold up
uh
okay i had to put my little spice on it
my little spiciness
all right bam
it's shared
it is shared guys
we are we are
we are we are live
we are live
we're live
okay so let's see here playing infinite
while you suffer
oh man
i gotta suffer like that
okay i can't hear anything
i feel like there's something wrong with
that oh oh never mind never mind i know
it's wrong
gotta
yeah there we go there we go
all right
all right
let's get into this let's get into this
what am i supposed to play single player
new
okay okay single player new
difficulty
hardest i assume
or is it hardcore which one is it
hardcore
or hard
i need clarification
attic won't be playing this again
which one is it
hardcore
or just hard
thank you
this is educational i don't need your
opinion boogeyman
i am very capable of
getting my own opinions on this game
without playing it
okay i'm very capable of doing that
so i'm gonna start this i gave you guys
plenty of time
to correct something if it wasn't it
but it seems like
no let me go ahead and turn off the chat
uh
off these don't want them ruining our
experience
i am gonna have to have my phone near me
because
i have a package coming
and i need to make sure
that i could see my phone
okay okay okay
let's just send a little message real
quick
all right all right all right there we
go there we go
uh my toothache feels a little bit
better i still gotta wait a little bit
before i can actually get it looked at i
still got a couple more days but today
right now currently
it's okay
uh what was i oh yeah i wanted to check
my packaging
make sure that i haven't got this yet
okay okay
let's start
mission one mission one
this looks weird
okay hold up
what is this
i don't even know what that is
[Music]
what are you doing up there with the gun
[Music]
look at him trying to hit me with that
[Music]
those people out there not trying to
attack me
the only got shurikens
is that my
oh i get shot one time it's a wrap
one time
okay
hold up hold up hold up hold on hold on
we gotta exit the game and restart
we gotta start that over again we gotta
run it back
we gotta run that back
[Music]
we gotta run that back again we gotta
run that back again
mission one
see i don't have to do no arcade stuff
so if i don't want to i ain't i will
reset however many times i want to
[Music]
you know just keep shooting
the shurikens
[Music]
do i have like
look at this dude
what does this do hold up
all right so got to use it there
gets wasted three points later you know
how it is man you know how it is we
gotta restart it again
[Music]
these people with the guns man
didn't ask for these people with the gun
all right all right that was a fluke
let's do it again
that was a little a little ridiculous
mission one let's do this again i don't
gotta rescue nothing i don't want to
[Music]
and i got two minutes to get to it too
oh got a rescue
now how do i get up there
oh gotcha
[Music]
all right let's do that again that was
that
that was a that was that was a glitch
let's do that again
i feel confident this right this run is
a go
[Music]
look at you over here trying with the
sword stuff look at you
look at you
i ain't feeling that
[Music]
yo
that that's a little ridiculous man
see at least it's a little bit realistic
i get shot you know i'm kind of messed
up you get shot in real life you messed
up
one two
got em
we're doing that again we're running
that back
i i got faith in this one man i got
faith in this run here
faith in this run here
everything
happens for a reason man
everything happens for a reason
[Music]
look i don't need your opinion there
lord metro i don't need your opinion all
right it's about memorization and i'm
gonna do it i'ma do it
i at least hope i get past mission one
i do hope i get past mission one
i just i just got to keep in mind that
these bullets is it's a wrap
when you get shot with these bullets
they don't play
oh my god
look cell jersey i don't need your
opinion uh i don't need you tell me if
okay guys give me one second i had my my
package is here i will be right back
it's it's important i gotta go grab this
i'm just tired of this stupid-ass
melding service that can never find our
actress
well apparently the mail service
couldn't find my stuff man
i don't understand you know what i got
i'm gonna just go to the mail place
tomorrow
one
well that really irritates me
i don't care about them hostages
[Music]
i'm frustrated because the male people
they're the most unreliable people in
this apartment
i don't understand how you can never
find my grip
[Music]
what are you guys doing
can i run
oh
oh
that was that was a little messed up
that dude was laying down like that
that's a little messed up i'ma be real
with you that was a little messed up
someone should have told me he was there
why didn't that chat keep me updated
you guys secretly hate me man i know it
[Music]
you guys secretly hate me
and it's okay if you secretly hate me
man i'm okay
[Music]
i got to use that y ability most likely
i don't know
[Music]
i don't like the sound it makes when i
get shocked
it's so disrespectful man that sound it
makes when i get shot
[Music]
look i'm not
i'm not trying to get anyone killed
i i feel like you can get up to the
second floor somehow
we got a 20 super chat from lord
sovereign
that's what you get for not saving them
hostages i don't know how i saved the
hostages i had access to
[Music]
you guys are just trying to troll me
i'm convinced
really
[Music]
bunch of nonsense man
we got this though we got this
[Music]
oh okay up on the d-pad
i don't know if i want to go up on the
d-pad i feel like you guys are trolling
me there
all right so up on the d-pad up on the
d-pad
[Music]
there we go okay okay
now i get back down
[Music]
you guys got me
messed up
mission one i'm tired of seeing this
mission one i should be able to skip
this
[Music]
all right so let's
let's get that
let's get all these let's stuck up here
jump down here kill him
[Music]
oh gotcha
[Music]
you can crouch crawl too
ah
i think that's like a super or something
why do i keep getting hit by that first
dude i don't need i'm better than that
why do i keep getting hit by that first
dude
i got something
for there we go
[Music]
got him
[Music]
do i have to get all the
the terrorists
do i have to get all the terrorists
all right all right
here we go
serious moment only
[Music]
all right this dude comes over here
[Music]
this shinobi gang get on my damn nerves
already
[Music]
no i don't care
ain't trying to put my name in anything
trying to win
we getting w's here we putting our name
on stuff
got me all messed up think i'm gonna put
my name on stuff
[Music]
there we go
throw a little kunai kunai
turn around get this dude
[Music]
all right here we go
got him
oh god
what was that big mother dude
someone needs to explain to me what he
was
because i wasn't feeling that
[Music]
can someone explain to me what what i
just missed was
[Music]
i don't know what i just missed
i don't know what i just missed man
someone
someone gotta tell me what i missed
what did i miss that's the boss
is that the boss for the whole game
is that the boss for the whole game
mission one
[Music]
i wasn't feeling that
i wasn't feeling that man
i felt like i could have done better
there
i feel like i deserve to do better there
[Music]
so he just turned around he just turned
a hat around what's that about just turn
around like that i don't feel like that
man that dude should have
kept facing forward but he decides just
turn around like that
[Music]
i could die into that dude i don't know
why
i think i think i got issues
oh you're counting off how much money i
would have to spend if i was
playing this in like the actual
arcade
oh god
so i'd have to spend nine dollars
already well my my broke ass couldn't do
that so
[Music]
i hate how that dude just turns around
i'ma have to kill him first
i can't just let him do that to me i
gotta i gotta turn i gotta kill
everybody first
and then turn around
[Music]
are you ever gonna salt
[Music]
don't think i won't just go crazy on
your ass
[Music]
wow
i gotta learn a little bit better way of
getting past that last part
[Music]
get
look man
[Applause]
i ain't trying to get that up close i
got a shuriken for a reason lord metro
i don't have to get up close to them
like that i'ma just i'ma just throw this
shuriken here over and over again man
throw the shuriken here over and over
again
[Music]
let's clear out everyone from this first
floor
[Music]
move up here
move down
[Music]
what you doing buddy
[Music]
that was some some nonsense
fight never seen anything
[Music]
don't need to kill anyone
let's just jump back up there
[Music]
wow
i kind of
i kind of like panicked there at the end
just a little bit
yeah it wasn't like i was intentionally
trying to panic but i did i did panic a
little bit
mission one
[Music]
god
[Music]
wow that dude just took my punch my kick
and he just
that off that's what he did man
that's what he did i don't i don't like
how i feel that
he was just like
[Music]
that was by accident i ain't mean to do
that
mission one
[Music]
oh my god
19
that can't be right
[Music]
oh
let's see but the the point is there
todd davis is that it don't have to do
that i hadn't got to continue over and
over again i don't got to spend his own
quarters all right i did good i think i
can play it as aggressively as he wants
he ain't spinning that
he ain't spitting that money
[Music]
i like the music though
i don't like that dude though
at least people don't respawn
[Music]
imma snatch that
[Music]
the dude that's prone there
is there
just a mess with me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right all right we good we good now
i'm i'm getting everything down a little
bit better
it's not it's not it's not the journey
it's the succession that we get there
man
that's what it is man
it's it's the fact that we get to the
end the end goal is the clue
[Music]
yeah i don't need to fight you i just
need that that witness man that witness
is all i needed
[Music]
yeah we getting rid of that
let's go
[Music]
stage
clear
after like 30 minutes
we we go we go ignore that
oh dude has a boomerang
i ain't feeling that
what is that
[Music]
how do i handle him
how do i prone you guys say i could prom
i need a prone first
i need to learn how to prone first
yes yes i know i gotta start from the
beginning that's fine i just gotta learn
how you prone how do i prone
mission one i got a prone i gotta learn
how to prone
hold up let's see
[Music]
i don't know how to prone i don't know
how i feel about that
i feel like i should learn how to prone
better
[Music]
okay hold the d-pad down
[Music]
no that's definitely not how you prone
[Music]
just gonna be real with you man that's
definitely not how you prone
[Music]
it's
definitely not how you throne
oh he came off off his little thing
didn't he
[Music]
i don't know how he killed this dude
[Music]
i don't know what i'm doing
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
may lay him
we'll have to see about the may land
thing
i don't know about that
i don't think i can
crawl over him
people saying all kinds of nonsense
i think you guys are trolling me man
i need that
i need that
[Music]
i need that
[Music]
wonder why it's so inconsistent
[Music]
wow it pushed him back
it pushed him back
[Music]
i definitely didn't mean to use that
so that's probably a wrap on this play
through
[Music]
get close and use your katana or k they
don't i don't know how to use my katana
[Music]
because for some reason i guess people
feel like just because
you know
that something's hard just because they
don't tell you control schemes
i guess that that's what makes games
hard don't tell you can control schemes
just don't tell control schemes man
that's what makes something hard
i'm so annoyed that i didn't get that
[Music]
so sick and tired of people not being
able to find my house man
mission one
that just ruined my whole day
that i have to deal with this
[Music]
i don't even want to play this anymore
after that i ain't gonna lie like i'm so
frustrated right now
how do you not find my apartment some
days but you find them other days like
that stuff makes no sense to me now i
gotta go to the post office to have
another conversation with them about not
being able to find my compartment
and losing stuff constantly
[Music]
i killed him before he threw that i
don't care what that says he was
definitely dead before that happened
i don't even care anymore
you guys are going to get the bare
minimum the two hours from me and then
i'm out
of here
i don't even care if i don't pass
mission one
[Music]
putting people
leaning down
[Music]
i don't know why just not feeling the
get hit one die thing like i just don't
feel like that's that's difficult like
that's literally
[Music]
if if you're putting your difficulty
behind just not getting hit
then
i don't know like literally they don't
move so
as long as i kept to it i would
eventually beat it
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
this isn't this is an arcade stop
putting me the arcade screen
mission one
[Music]
oh
[Music]
they're billion dollars in debt because
they they're they're worthless sometimes
man and i'm not saying it's every one of
them it's the people that work at my
district
oh my god dude and not to mention they
shoot yellow projectiles at you
behind a yellow actual wall
so explain to me how that's difficult
that's just
there's a difference between making
something difficult and then making
something artificially difficult and
this is making stuff artificially
difficult
[Music]
i could be playing halo infinite right
now but for some reason i'm playing this
stuff
no
and then they come behind me
jump up kill this dude
let's jump down and just kill these two
real quick no
i mean do i really is he gonna jump up
[Music]
i wish you could just reset
like it's dumb that they make me go back
and actually like if i dive one time i
feel like i need to just go ahead and
die the rest so i can reset but then
they make me do this stupid greatest
shinobi ranking acting like being a
shinobi needs to be on a ranking anyway
i don't care how it rolled back in the
day brah i don't care
i'm so glad i missed out on the arcade
nonsense
[Music]
what you doing what you doing
no
use the sword addicts use the sword
addicts
it's my fault for listening to you guys
man it's my fault for listening to you
guys
[Music]
i take responsibility for my actions
listening to you guys definitely part of
those responsibilities
i don't even know why
this dude sometimes lets me hit him
sometimes he doesn't
[Music]
i actually really enjoyed uh
uh ninja gai and i'm not real i'm not
enjoying this at all
because these were made for monetary
value these were made to to have you die
over and over again so you could so they
could constantly make money off of you
that that's the problem that i'm having
with this there's a loop like i don't
want to keep playing this like i'm not
enjoying this
[Music]
he
um
[Music]
uh i think i think i'm gonna give you
guys an hour at this game i'm not
playing this for two hours
it's just not happening i'm not enjoying
this i'm just not like i don't like this
game
[Music]
i actually really enjoyed ninja gaiden
like i really did i'm not enjoying this
like i actually wanted to learn the
stages on ninja gaiden like i don't know
why just something about this game just
not clicking with me like not even a
little bit
[Music]
no i'm not gonna lower the difficulty
i'm just gonna do this where i'm
supposed to and then move on because i
just don't like this game
and it's not that it's hard it's just i
don't i don't like it like i hit that
dude and somehow he still got hit off
like it makes no sense
i'd rather play halo infinite right now
i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna lie i'd rather play halo
infinite right now
two
[Music]
good
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
i don't understand how you take on
people that's lying on the
i might as well just die because i've
already lost to hell
i'm really upset over this post office
thing
i'm really upset over this post office
thing i'm so sick and tired of having
issues with this
[Music]
i wasn't even
[Music]
you guys might not even get an hour
ahead of me on this game because i'm
really not enjoying this game at all
like i hate this damn game
mission one
eight
gotta play this old ass game
i'd rather play battle toes than this
[Music]
okay
[Music]
um
mission one this is all i'm doing the
rest of the show
is just walking str
i'm just so
frustrated today
[Music]
i'm not gonna talk to the chat i'm gonna
try to focus on this dumbass game
[Music]
oh
[Music]
got dudes sitting on the ground
i don't
[Music]
because i'm being made to play on the
hardest difficulty
mission one
[Music]
at least the response sometimes a little
bit better than it was on the other game
i do feel like when i press something it
actually presses
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh my god
one
i just don't like it like
[Music]
you know i get it this was this was the
the
that game back in the day but it's not
that day anymore guys it's not that date
let's leave this game and all the other
nonsense back in the past where it
belongs
[Music]
i'm so annoyed how do you prone in this
game
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i got about 35 minutes left
about 35 minutes left
and then i'm done
[Music]
i am so done
you have no idea
[Music]
at least i'm learning how to get past
this part
at least i could get here easier
i'm improving guys be proud of me
i'm gonna use that little
just 30 minutes left aj
30 minutes left man
30 minutes left
we could get through this 30 minutes
i got this 30 minutes
[Music]
30 minutes left with this game
[Music]
got 30 minutes left of this nonsense
got 30. look man i was told to play on
hardest so i'm playing on hardest i
ain't doing this again you guys aren't
tricking me to play this again
just because i didn't play it on the
hardest difficulty
it's easier for me to close out of the
game
and go back into it than it is for me to
do that
[Music]
at least i'm learning though
i might hate the game but at least i'm
learning
[Music]
look at this
dude
[Music]
come here hostage
[Music]
nah i'm not going down there
wow i didn't mean to jump down
let's just reset it
it's best the resets
mission one
i'm in a stream
i don't know don't worry about that
right now
what
for where
well i don't know
why do you always wait for me to do
something before you decide you need to
do something
that's a better question
[Music]
see now i'm just getting upset
see now
the upsetness is coming out now
[Music]
look at this dude
gotcha
[Music]
yeah i gotta do the down thing that i
hit them both
this shredder looking dude
shredder
not allowed to i have to play it on the
heart's difficulty
mission one
20 minutes left man 20 minutes
i don't like the stupid interface
[Music]
might be a rat man
this this might be a wrap for me
i might go stream something else
i'm just not enjoying this like i'm not
gonna sit here and keep playing
something i'm just not enjoying
my back's hurting
[Music]
you should be able to just reset like
this isn't a stupid arcade
this is the part that annoys you the
most is resetting that's the part that
annoys me the most
[Music]
[Music]
cognito i'm i'm pretty sure cognito said
play this on the hardest difficulty
[Music]
i don't even care i'm wasting it
[Music]
uh
[Music]
look man
[Music]
look i will put it on the hard
difficulty
on the hard difficulty
just because you guys claim that's what
he wants but i'm not doing anything more
like i'm not going any lower than that
because i'm not doing this again
[Music]
it's not the look of defeat dude i'm
just not enjoying it i can play a game
i'm frustrated with as long as i'm
enjoying it i'm just not enjoying this
game
[Music]
two three
three
[Music]
i don't see a difference between heart
and heart is i'm gonna be real with you
[Music]
i don't know
[Music]
yeah it is a lot easier isn't it i jump
down
[Music]
oh
i got here
i don't even know what that's about
mission one
wasted like
an hour if you guys are right about me
playing on the hardest difficulty
[Music]
for homeboy doesn't even
good
[Music]
damn it's like a
yeah i did
all right
[Music]
let's just get to the end
[Music]
it is a lot easier on hard instead of
hardest whatever it
two
was
[Music]
[Music]
two
[Music]
[Music]
go
go
[Music]
all right i gotta find a better way of
handling that dude
i don't know how i didn't get hit by
that but we we're not gonna we're not
gonna complain we don't complain here
well i complain but we're not
complaining about that
we're not complaining about that
we're going to let that go
that that was meant to be
uh let's go and reset
mission one people sitting there
counting how many quarters it would take
for
me to play as much as i've played
[Music]
gotta take the hostages before you could
do anything it looks like
[Music]
i feel like i got like
self-esteem issues if i keep letting you
guys it get me into these situations
like this
some something something's wrong with me
at this point it's got to be me
like man i keep letting people get me to
play these games that i'm just not like
like
i don't know what i'd be doing man i
gotta stop it though i really do gotta
stop it i'm not fighting this green deal
green dude's too much we're not fighting
green dude we love
we hype
people up around here man
[Music]
let's get that dude
nope hmm
okay see one
two
three then reload right okay one
two
three
reload
oh barely made that barely made that
that green dude wanted some man he
wanted some
oh god
okay okay okay
okay
uh
i don't know if i'm hitting them right
i don't know if i'm doing any of this
right
let's just
yeah
ninjutsu oh yeah the white thing
all right let's try it
do i have to get me against the wall or
something
okay okay
mission one finished welcome to bonus
day bonus stage
what is the bonus stage
[Music]
what was that
mission two
wasn't feeling that guys i ain't gonna
lie i wasn't feeling that
i don't know what was that about
[Music]
now i gotta start the whole damn thing
again don't i
don't
be honest with you guys man
[Music]
oh you can only go in certain areas okay
[Music]
oh okay see that's
that's like really hard to like really
grasp where that is
[Music]
okay
i got you
[Music]
this dude's inching his way up to me man
[Music]
he's really testing me man
i feel very uncomfortable with him doing
oh oh okay i'm missing someone
i'm missing a hostage somewhere
i'm missing a hostage somewhere
there's the hostage
that was the hostage i was missing
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
okay all right
all right buddy
i got you
let's do this again let's run this back
[Music]
start this whole nonsense over again one
this whole thing over again let's do it
not really
i'm okay hating you guys in my head
[Music]
i am i'm not definitely
not liking you guys
[Music]
[Music]
now we gotta do the second stage
[Music]
get this
i could i could have did a little bit
better on that one all right could've
did a little bit better on
what is going on
let's just reset it
mission one let's just reset
i don't feel comfortable man i don't
feel comfortable
[Music]
oh my god
we got a two dollar super chat did you
buy any games this black friday
obvi uh oh nah i didn't really get
anything
next black friday i i i think i'll have
a
you know be a better spot next friday
next black friday
i always be saying every year i'ma save
up and get something black friday but
then my dumb ass never does
[Music]
no
[Music]
at least i get i'm learning guys i'm
learning
[Music]
i am learning
i don't want this dude jumping after me
[Music]
wow i hit him
i hit him i definitely feel like i hit
him
i feel like i really did hit him
i don't know how i feel about that guys
like i hit him
oh no
oh my
this stupid ui
no i'm not doing the arcade thing all
right
mission one like who am i gonna play
this with in my actual
relatively family like ain't nothing
like that's happening
[Music]
mm-hmm
[Music]
you bought island awake and links
awakening that's what's up man
i was gonna review the pokemon game for
you guys but
i didn't know what the the realm would
want you know
would want us to review games like that
i need to kill that green dude i don't
know why i'm making the mistake and not
shooting him
[Music]
oh my god man
thank you
[Music]
wow
i gotta be better on that
[Music]
like
i don't know why i'm making stupid
see look i i will literally call out to
you guys this whole thing and watch how
accurate i am it's like my mind doesn't
care because i don't care so there's
gonna be people here hit the mall
then the gun dude jump over it jump
for some reason i can't hit him
the green dude
gotta go back a little bit
get him
[Music]
i think another green dude's here
come on
[Music]
[Music]
all right the three
one
two
three
[Music]
the fire i gotta dump there
oh my god
gotta go through all these troubles just
to start the mission over again
[Music]
uh i
i ain't really
i really don't care
i'ma give you guys
the best of my ability show
[Music]
handle this dude
[Music]
oh my god i'm tired of getting hit with
that dude
[Music]
that great dude's annoying i don't want
to get hit by him
wow
guess i didn't hit him hit that fast
enough
[Music]
dudes
[Music]
[Music]
one two
three
oh man
oh there's an arcade version
i didn't know that
wow that's the first time i've ever been
hit
by melee dude
mission one mission
one
what sounds good to eat guys
cause i gotta go get eat food after this
i've been ate nothing all day almost
what sounds good to you guys
what kind of food
makes the most sense
now keep in mind i'm very frustrated
because i was because i had to play this
game but what what food makes the most
sense
oh
look at you
looking to eat when i leave here man
looking to eat when i leave here
[Music]
i really don't got no leftovers
unfortunately
i should have got more food from
thanksgiving
[Music]
i didn't know
so that's all me
come on
two
[Music]
one
two
three
i think maybe i hit him to stop him from
doing that move
i can't remember what i did
i'm tired of that
oh
shinobi
wasn't this on the sega
my am i
recalling that correctly
was it on the sega
[Music]
did i get that right with this game on
the sega
someone ex
someone make sure i know what game this
came from i'm pretty sure it was on the
sega
was it on the sega or am i getting these
mixed up or is on the neo geo kio
[Music]
right now
good
[Music]
i'm just gonna
stay crouched because to me
even though i feel like i hit him first
clearly
the game doesn't read that
i do so jay that's fine
but you in here watching my sucky ass
aren't you
[Music]
got a bunch of backseat gamers in here
man
[Music]
gotta love them gotta love
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
oh i try to get out of my way man
try to get out of my way
look man
i just don't i'm not used to these old
games jay man
[Music]
oh that's that sucks this thing's yeah
let me just reset that
mission one
two
[Music]
i'm starting to learn the timing a
little bit better
[Music]
learning the timing better man learning
the timing better
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
do i got a gun or is that a share again
oh my gosh i didn't know he would throw
that that was my that was my stupidity
i hate
mission one
mission one
[Music]
two three
[Music]
oh man i meant to
it kind of
it's kind of irritating that there's a
crouch button and you have a platforming
button so sometimes i'll be meeting just
to do a lower
like shuriken move but i'm moving down
for floor like it's kind of annoying a
little bit
[Music]
i guess it's my fault because i might be
you know spamming a little bit panicking
at the last minute
so that might be my fault
and i looked at the chat
got myself
murked
mission one
i won't be playing another game like
this
[Music]
i mean it doesn't take much to do this
but it's still annoying
[Music]
wow sometimes they come to me sometimes
they don't
mission one
[Music]
oh my gosh
mission one
[Music]
i don't want to waste that that ability
again
oh my god that dude needs to go
somewhere
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
let's just let this thing throw himself
off
i feel like he's easier to hit
i don't know
two
three
[Music]
so i missed one
somewhere i missed one and they're
probably gonna spawn going back too
oh that thing spawned
all right
wow
wow
[Music]
you guys just sit there and talk all the
smack you want it it's not bothering me
i really don't care
oh i'm dead
[Music]
probably give it about five more tries
guys and then i'm done i am in this at 7
30.
i gave it an hour and a half
[Music]
i'm just not enjoying it i'm really not
[Music]
[Music]
be disappointed in me man like it ain't
bothering me i'm not gonna continue to
play something that i'm just not
enjoying you're not gonna get me to do
that
i'm not gonna sit here
and continuously learn this when i'm not
enjoying the game
[Music]
[Music]
two
[Music]
go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one
[Music]
mission one
oh
[Music]
oh my god i couldn't even see that
because of the yellow screen
one
[Music]
do
[Music]
go
[Music]
go
go
[Music]
go
so you gotta let the fireball then go
back all right
good
[Music]
i hit him a couple times i don't like
this weird
like location
[Music]
two
[Music]
oh my god
good
hurry up
oh
i'm done
i'm gonna get to this oh i gotta one
more chance
mission one finished welcome to bonus
day i don't even know what this bonus
stage is
i just don't want to play it man i'm
gonna be real with you i just don't want
to play
[Music]
i don't even know what that does
[Music]
go
[Music]
two
[Music]
wow
thought i had an extra
a couple of seconds late left
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
mission one
good
[Music]
mission one
my back's hurting
[Music]
three
[Music]
chubby was a master system
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did
two
three
[Music]
[Music]
well at least i got the first level down
to a point i still gotta get the timing
of fighting homeboy
i don't like having to use that ability
but i'm having such a hard time getting
this
this timing
hurry up
i don't
it's like i'm barely missing it by hair
gotta get that timing down
finished welcome to bonus stage
[Music]
mission two
[Music]
i just got slapped
[Music]
oh
[Music]
three
[Music]
[Music]
a helicopter what's that about
[Music]
[Music]
man it's hard to tell where they show up
though man
[Music]
oh that dude just got right back up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you gotta hit these things twice i
assume
[Music]
dude
[Music]
[Music]
whoa folks
that's where i'm ending the stream
i did an hour and a half
and i'm i'm fine with that i'm fine with
that i don't need to do any more than
that
i appreciate we're coming through
we'll go to the post show real quick
so
let's talk about
shinobi
i mean it was an okay game i just didn't
like it i don't know why i just don't
like that game i don't like the way it's
structured and it's just because i don't
play i haven't played a whole lot of
those type of games
i mean this
and in the other game
isn't really the only games i've played
back then like consistently without like
not caring anymore
and i think that's like the biggest
issue that i have
i got the willpower to do it
like
i don't like the gameplay
so if i don't like the gameplay i'm not
going to learn how to play it because i
don't care
this game took out yeah that's all it is
is is just
it's just
memorization you guys noticed that i was
getting to the
uh deep
i was consistently getting through the
first stage
you know halfway through the stream
pretty consistently and you know
that's all this game really is is
memorization and people that can do it
kudos to you i can do it if i actually
put time into it uh i actually really
enjoy ninja gaiden more than i enjoyed
this game i don't know why
i just
i felt like ninja gaiden was a little
bit more quick pace and maybe that's why
i enjoyed that game a little bit more uh
this game's not bad it's just i i
wouldn't replay you know i've actually
considered going back and beating ninja
gaiden but this game i don't know maybe
it's because ninja gaiden i felt like i
had more options too with the shurikens
and and stuff like that like i felt like
it was a lot more quick pace than this
game but this game's not bad it's just
not for me
if that makes any sense to you it's just
not for me but you know
yes i got wrecked lmp i got wrecked
i got wrecked i might try to do like
a high light stream or something of how
bad it was i i i only beat the first
stage
you know i got halfway through the
second stage but it's like i said like
if i don't like a game i'm not going to
continuously
punish myself to learn it i just wasn't
enjoying the game i enjoyed
shinobi that's why i i streamed it like
damn near three and a half hours i
streamed that game for a minute because
i myself was thoroughly enjoying that
game so i had no problem
putting more time into that game now you
guys can ask some questions in the chat
uh because i'll answer them if you have
any sort of questions that you want in
the chat
you can definitely ask them
you guys got any questions
any questions man it has more modern
sensibilities i'd agree
i don't know i just like ninja gaiden i
really really really like ninja gaiden
it was a it was a fun experience
fun experience guys fun experience i
really enjoyed it
don't feel bad these old games are hard
i don't even think that they're hard i
think a lot of these older games were
designed to be an arcade so they put
like gimmicky things that get you killed
intentionally is
uh in what gen
um
i started playing
i would say i played
games to the nes and snes but i didn't
really like thoroughly have my own
system until the n64
uh my mom claims i had an snes but i
don't remember it i was probably too
young i mean look sega 1886 that was
before i was born
so this game came out before i was born
shinobi 3 though chief kiss it also has
a life bar look
i'm not oh i'm not against streaming
older games again it's not something
that i wouldn't
put thought into it's just something
that you know
uh there might have to be another little
little quota thing that man we might
have to do more stuff
but as far as you know me not i i
it was a good game i can't say like it
was a horrible game but i definitely
i definitely enjoyed ninja gaiden more
you agree about shinobi three i might
try shinobi three in the future
i might try shinobi three in the future
we'll have to see what kind of uh
community go we we can
set but i might try something in the
future i don't know yet
we'll have to see guys we'll have to see
but i'm gonna go ahead and end it there
man i appreciate everyone for coming
through
uh you know
had damn dear almost 60 of you at one
time
it was it was definitely a very i
wouldn't say challenging very annoying
time
but uh i enjoyed it